Spaghetti Carbonara sind so ein richtig
klassischer Streitpunkt in der Küche mit
Sahne ohne Sahne oder vielleicht mit
Pilzen heute finden wir heraus Welcher
Star kocht das beste Spaghetti Carbonara
Rezept hat es treten an Jamie Oliver
Gordon Ramsay und Steffen Henssler wir
hoffentlich heute nicht schon wieder
gewinnt wir haben uns Burger angeschaut
wir haben uns Bolognese angeschaut ich
habe richtig Bock heute herauszufinden
wer die perfekten Spaghetti Carbonara
macht deshalb legen wir direkt los mit
dem Rezept von Jamie Oliver wenn wir uns
die Zutaten anschauen dann sehen wir
traditionelle Zutaten ich mag um ehrlich
zu sein sehr gerne traditionelle
Spaghetti Carbonara das heißt ohne Sahne
ich bin aber geschmacklich auch offen
für Version mit Sahne deshalb werde ich
mich heute wirklich nur auf den
Geschmack konzentrieren und natürlich
auch die anderen Faktoren Schale
schwarzen Pfeffer Pecorino also
Schafskäse Eier und eine Knoblauchzehe
die ist glaube ich das einzige was nicht
ganz traditionell ist sehr interessante
Techniken bei diesem Rezept ich nehme
erstmal meinen schwarzen Pfeffer in
Körnern und fülle ihn in einen Mörser
die jetzt groß denn wir wollen ein
Pfeffer Pulver erhalten welcher dadurch
bekommen dass wir mörsern und
anschließend sieben das reicht schon ihr
seht wir haben jetzt grobe
pfeffersplitter und im Inneren des
Pfeffers diese feinen pulverartigen
Molekülen die wir jetzt verwenden werden
um laut Jamie den scharfen Part vom
Pfeffer für unser Gericht zu haben jetzt
will ich mal gucken ob das so gut
funktioniert wie Jamie sagt oh ja guck
mal dann fällt direkt schon was durch
das ist jetzt die Essenz des Pfeffers
die wir für unsere Carbonara brauchen
Nudelwasser kocht und ist gesalzen wir
geben unseres Spaghetti hinein die
brauchen zwölf Minuten wir kochen die
komplett aldente als nächstes kümmern
wir uns um unsere one Schale dafür
schneide ich mir bei Daumen breites
Stück ab wir brauchen wirklich eine
ganze Ecke und ihr seht schon wann
Schale hat unfassbar viel Fett das
Gericht hat wirklich in sich meins ist
halt eine relativ traditionelle
Carbonara so wie ich sie schon häufiger
gemacht habe wenn mein tiktok Channel
abonniert hat hat das vielleicht schon
mal gesehen guck mal in der Beschreibung
vorbei blog.shop auch auf Instagram
kommt ganz bald was auf euch zu warten
Arbeit ein Ende küss eure Herzen ich bin
schon sehr aufgeregt deshalb ach so und
auf Instagram wisst ihr als allererstes
Bescheid über alle Updates deshalb
einfach mal Reihenfolgen fange an in die
kalte Pfanne geben wir die wandschale zu
der kalten sonnenschale eine angemischte
Knoblauchzehe wir können uns jetzt um
die Source denn die Source besteht aus
lediglich einem Ei und Pecorino Käse 20
Gramm mit super viel geht er nicht rein
und
Schale kriegt langsam Farbe wir geben
einen Teil unseres Pfeffers an Zeit ist
gekommen wir nehmen den Knoblauch raus
ihr habt richtig gehört er hat seinen
Job getan hier drüben machen wir jetzt
die Hitze komplett aus und wir geben die
Nudeln mitsamt ein bisschen Wasser in
unsere Pfanne bis das zwischen auch da
gehen wir nach und nach ein bisschen
Nudelwasser dazu wir halten langsam aber
sicher eine schöne Soße jetzt auf der
Hitze hat dafür so eine eigene Technik
bzw der schwenkt dass die ganze Zeit so
gibt dann beim Schwenken das Ei dazu das
Spaghetti Carbonara es gibt alles wie es
ist in den Teller guckt euch das an
cremige emulgierte Schicht um die Nudeln
dazwischen die knusprige waren Schale
wir gehen noch mal mit ein bisschen von
unserer Pfeffer Essenz dran und reiben
ein wenig frischen Pecorino drüber danke
Jamie du hast es drauf ich sage euch
ehrlich es sieht mindestens so gut aus
wie bei Jamie Oliver das liegt aber an
den Nudeln nicht vielleicht besser
sondern die Nudeln sorgen halt viel mehr
noch für eine geile Illusion unten ist
wirklich eine richtig dicke Soße wir
haben keine Sahne verwendet
und ich probiere
[Musik]
das ist ein Anfang ich bin froh dass mir
gelungen ist weil dieses Ei noch hinein
zu tröpfeln während man das ganze dann
die ganze Zeit bewegt ist schon echt
anspruchsvoll das hat aber alles
geklappt denkt euch euren Teil die
genaue Bewertung kommt zum Schluss mit
allen Kategorien machen wir weiter mit
dem nächsten Spaghetti Carbonara die ist
auch wirklich in sich haben
kurze triggerwarnung an alle Italiener
was ihr jetzt seht hat für euch
wahrscheinlich überhaupt nichts mit
einer Carbonara zu tun für Gordon Ramsay
allerdings schon deshalb habe ich auf
eine gewisse Art und Weise Hoffnung für
das was wir jetzt kochen die Zutaten
erstmal Petersilie Chili Parmesan
Champignons bacon in Streifen Erbsen
Krämpfe fraîche Eier und Knoblauch
wirklich besser aushalten wenn ihr Stolz
Italiener seid ja wir fangen an
wie er ist so dünn wie er vor allem ist
aufs Brett ich glaube er hat das
irgendwie so als Cornwall Version von
Carbonara bezeichnet und hat das dann so
in anderthalb Zentimeter breite Stücke
geschnitten ich habe etwas so liebe in
die Pfanne gegeben dazu kommt jetzt der
Bacon also bisschen Farbe dran gekommen
ist nächstes Knoblauch der wird auch
sofort um auch interessant er gibt jetzt
den Knoblauch schon dazu und danach erst
kommt das was er als nächstes schneiden
und das sind unsere Pilze er sagt nicht
ganz dünnstein schon so ein bisschen
dass sie noch ein bisschen Biss haben
jetzt kommt dazu Champignons als
nächstes eine Chili und er sagt
nicht schön aus als ein bisschen Schärfe
in der Spaghetti Carbonara ja ich meine
die Schärfe hatten wir ja gerade auch
aber in Form von schwarzen Pfeffer das
hat noch ein bisschen mehr Sinn gemacht
als jetzt eine Chili zu verwenden kann
er nimmt einfach die ganze Chili und
haut die hier dazu Nudeln ins Wasser al
dente kochen wir langsam Farbe dran wie
immer sind auch die original Videos
verlinkt falls ihr die Referenzen
verstehen wollt guckt auch bei den
Köchen vorbei
Erbsen rein gefroren das finde ich auch
interessant dass wir Knoblauch rot dünn
geschnitten so bedeutend viel früher als
Erbsen tiefgefroren rein machen das
macht auch nicht so viel Sinn für mich
kümmern wir uns um die Soße ein Ei
Parmesan Creme fraîche
daran gehen wir jetzt ein bisschen
Leitungswasser damit es nicht stockt
jetzt haben wir eine schöne Konsistenz
die Nudeln sind fertig gekocht gegeben
sie mit zu dem
ist das nur Soße noch nicht wir geben es
mit in die Pfanne sowie ein zwei Kellen
Nudelwasser sag einmal durchmischen wenn
ihr es noch zwischen hört ist es noch zu
heiß gehen wir noch mal mit ein bisschen
Wasser rein und wenn es nicht mehr
zischt können wir unsere Mischung
hineingeben und durchmischen Petersilie
davon nimmt er auch jede Menge wenn wir
das jetzt Carbonara nennen machen wir
uns mitschuldig glaube
guckt euch das an es sieht verdammt noch
mal nicht schlecht aus wir landen das
Baby mitten darauf ein wenig Parmesan
noch drüber dann nehmen wir uns eine
Gabel und bei der Carbonara darf man mit
Sicherheit auch mit Löffel essen gucken
wir uns das Ding mal genauer an also wir
haben hier das Grün von den Erbsen die
Bacon Chips schöne oben drüber
geriebenen Parmesan wir haben
Champignons wir haben auch eine schöne
soßeigkeit muss ich wirklich sagen das
klingt auch gut
boah Schärfe von der Chili ist schön
ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz weit
in der Ferne erinnert mich das an
Spaghetti Carbonara also es hat wirklich
auch vom Grundton her nicht so viel vom
klassischen Carbonara Geschmack ich
hoffe das wird sehr sehr schwer zu
bewerten oder
was wir nicht machen wollen ist die
Pasta disqualifizieren weil sie keine
klassische Carbonara ist wie ich das
ganze jetzt geschmacklich bewerte in der
Frage nach einer Carbonara werden wir
sehen interessant was alle Male wirklich
ich esse das mit Herz auf richtig lecker
wir sehen uns im nächsten Gericht und
zwar Steffen Henssler jetzt ist es Zeit
für den meisten für Steffen Henssler für
den zweimaligen Gewinner des Starkoch
Bett ist er arbeitet nicht mit Schale in
seinem Video sagt man kann es auch tun
wir machen aber alles identisch wie er
schneiden deshalb einen schönen
Bauchspeck in grobe dicke Streifen wenn
er nicht ganz so viel Fett hat wie man
alles gibt Stefan etwas Olivenöl in
seine Pfanne ist also ist das auch
wieder eine schnelle Nummer das ist eine
schnelle Nummer eine Sache ist
interessant an dem Gericht er verwende
Sahne nichtsdestotrotz ist das nicht
eine klassische deutsche Carbonara
sondern es ist schon irgendwie so ein
mischmasch-ding ihr werdet gleich
verstehen wovon ich rede wir trennen
Eier und verwenden nur das Eigelb bzw
nur die Eigelbe wir brauchen nämlich
sechs Stück jetzt haben wir sechs Eigelb
in unserer Schüssel und reiben dazu 100
g Parmesankäse jetzt gehen wir zum
geriebenen Käse noch Sahne hinzu und
zwar nicht zu knapp 150 ml und verrühren
das Ganze zu einer Masse geschmacklich
sollte das auf jeden Fall punkten können
die Nudeln sind identite das Kochen hat
eine Ente gehen Sie in die Pfanne
und fügen es zusammen mit ich weiß nicht
ob die Mengenangaben 1 zu 1 Stimmen aus
dem Rezept weil wir haben gefühlt schon
ein bisschen mehr Soße aber wir haben
uns auf jeden Fall an die Angaben
gehalten ich sage mal ehrlich mein
schaden tut es nicht ne die Soße ist
zwar relativ flüssig aber ich glaube
geschmacklich gibt uns alles was wir
wollen wir richten das einmal schön an
und dann wird probiert so sieht das bei
Steffen aus
schmecken scheint ihm zu tun aber wir
haben halt viel viel viel viel viel viel
viel viel viel viel viel viel viel viel
viel mehr Soße er hat in seinem Video
nur so einen kleinen Shop verwendet und
ich dachte halt weil wir haben es nach
Mengenangabe am Ende gemacht mit Sahne
es ist sehr viel Flüssigkeit aber
schmecken wird bestimmt trotzdem schöne
gelbe Farbe vom Eigelb oben drauf
knusprigen gehe noch mal richtig schön
überall in die Soße rein das ist eine
geile Sache mit der vielen Soße wenn man
so schöne Gabel und probieren
hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet die hat
schon viel viel viel von der geilen auch
klassischen Kamera das einzige was der
ältet ist halt Sahne aber ist das
schlecht
das sind richtig gute Spaghetti
Carbonara es waren alle drei Gerichte
heute auch wenn es teilweise nicht
Spaghetti Carbonara waren kommen wir zur
Bewertung drei Kategorien
Wand doppelt gewertet ist fangen wir an
mit dem Aufwand Gordon Ramsey relativ
kleinteiliger Einkauf wir brauchen viele
verschiedene Sachen die wir aber alle in
einem Supermarkt bekommen sein Rezept
geht super schnell wie die anderen auch
vier von fünf möglichen Sternen Jamie
Oliver one schade zu bekommen relativ
schwer schwere Techniken die man
anwenden muss dieses ganze emulgieren
und so drei von fünf möglichen Punkten
Henssler 55 schneller Einkaufen schnell
gemacht kommen wir zu den Kosten es ist
immer die gezeigte Portion die ungefähr
gleich groß war Garden 10 €, vier von
fünf möglichen Punkt Jamie 8 € 50 obwohl
die Kontrolle benutzt haben weil einfach
so wenig anderes dabei war fünf von fünf
möglichen Punkten Henssler 12 Euro 6
Eigelb sind 6 Eier 100 Gramm Parmesan
das geht ins Geld drei von fünf
Möglichkeiten jetzt ist noch alles offen
kommen wir zum Geschmack wie hat mir das
Ganze geschmeckt ich muss sagen die
Pasta von Gordon hat mir viel zu gut
geschmeckt viel besser als sie
eigentlich schmecken sollte die Schärfe
war geil die Cremigkeit war geil sogar
Pilze und Erbsen waren eigentlich nice
ich habe dafür entschieden acht von zehn
Punkten zu geben Jamie 9 von 10 Kranke
Cremigkeit Originalzutaten Schärfe vom
Pfeffer das war richtig geil viel mehr
kann man nicht machen das stimmt einer
bleibt noch übrig schafft es Steffen
Henssler wieder heute nicht acht von
zehn möglichen weil irgendwie es war zu
flüssig es hat nicht so diesen super
intensiven Geschmack weil es sehr
gestreckt war mit der vielen Sahne und
so das war's heute nicht wir dürfen aber
Jamie gratulieren der das wahrscheinlich
niemals sieht und jetzt auch überhaupt
nicht juckt trotzdem herzlichen
Glückwunsch stell mir an dieser Stelle
krankes Rezept kann ich jedem empfehlen
danke fürs zusehen hier an der Seite
gibt es einen für dich vorgeschlagenes
Video darunter kannst du den Kanal
abonnieren Tag bis zum nächsten Video
passt dann ne